one problem aight problem eight how many
more degrees of arc are there in one
fourth of a circle then one fifth of the
circle alright so one fourth of a circle
one fourth of a circle has how many
degrees so it's one-fourth times the
degrees in a circle so it's what 360
degrees which is equal to what what's
360 divided by four it's 90 degrees
right one for x 360 s 90 degrees so
that's one-fourth that's one-fourth of a
circle alright one-fifth of the circle x
360 it equals with 360 divided by 5
which is equal to 7 d to write 35 right
72 so that equals 72 degrees that's in
one fifth of a circle and they're asking
how many more degrees of an arc are
there and win one fourth of a circle
then one fifth so what's 90 minus 72
well that's 18 degrees that's answer B
next problem problem 9 problem 9 draw
the axes go and then they have see they
have a curve curve that looks something
like this goes to the origin and it
looks like it's symmetric it goes like
this it keeps going and they tell us
this is the point this is the point
minus 6 comma 0 then they tell us well
do they tell a little at this point they
say that this is 1 this is 1 this is the
point 7 comma 6 up here 7 comma 6 and
they're saying that this is 6 comma 0 0
they don't draw a little point there
which makes me a little suspicious maybe
they just forgot based on the graph of
the function f above what are the values
of x for which f of X is negative so
when is f of X negative well it's
negative in this range from from here to
here
that's when it's negative so what values
of x are it's negative well at zero it's
0 so 0 doesn't count so X has to be
greater than 0 x is greater than zero
because we can't count 0 because at 0
the function is actually 0 and we want
to know negative and zero isn't the
negative number and what does X have to
be less than well this is 0 point 6 so X
has to be less than six so that is
choice B not too hard huh you just have
to say when does it dip below the x-axis
well between when X is between 0 & 6
next problem let me switch colors a
figure above what you have to draw the
figure above shows the dimensions of a
pedestal constructed a four to four
layers of marble each layers of
rectangular solid that is one foot high
and has a square base how many cubic
feet of marble yes I have to draw this
so at the top the top I have a cube that
looks like that it's one by one by one
then you have another marble looks like
this it's one high and then of course
you know it's too wide right so let's
just start doing the volumes immediately
the volume of the top one is one the
volume of the second one is what 2 x 2 x
1 it's 2 times 2 times 1 which equals
for the volume of the next one is what
goes out like this
it's 3 x 3 x 1 right so what is its
volume 3 x 3 x 1 this is 3 x 3 x 1 so it
equals 9 i think you start seeing the
pattern here and then finally we have
the fourth one the fourth one looks like
looks like that i'm not going to draw it
fully you get the point it's going to be
4 4 x 4 x 14 x 4 x 1 which is equal to
16 so the volume of all of them combined
is 1 plus 4 plus 9 plus 16 that's 5 plus
9 plus 16 that's 14 plus 16 vet equals
30 and that's choice C next problem
problem 11 problem 11 if x and y are
positive integers and for to the 2x is
equal to 2y what is X in terms of Y
whenever you see something like this and
you see a forward to just convert them
all to the same base so how do you write
for with as a you know to the you know
to to some powers for write how do you
write for is a function as a expression
with two exponential expression with to
my brain is malfunctioning well that's
the same thing as 2 squared right so
that's 2 squared times 2 to the X is
equal to 2 to the y we add exponents
when we multiply two numbers with the
same base so you get that's 2 to the 2
plus X is equal to Y sorry is equal to 2
to the Y so 2 plus X must equal y 2 plus
X is equal to Y they do this all the
time of the smt so you should really get
these are using problems if you just
remember to do this and remember your
exponent rules and they want X in terms
of Y so subtract two from both sides you
get x is equal to y minus 2 and that is
choice a next problem problem 12 problem
12
if the degree measures of the angles of
a triangle are the ratio of two to three
to four how many degrees does the
measure of the largest angle exceed the
measure of the smallest angle so let's
say that the smallest angle is why don't
know let's say the smallest angle is 2x
right then the middle angle is going to
be 3x and then the fort the largest
angle is going to be 4x right and if I
were to draw a triangle it would look
like this 2 X 3 X 4 X 4 X naught 45 for
X so they all have to add up to 180
because they're the angles of a triangle
so 2x plus 3x plus 4 x is going to equal
180 and what is this this is 2 plus 3 is
5 plus 4 is 9 so 9 x is equal to 180 x
is equal to 20 right so the smallest
angle is going to be 40 degrees and the
largest angle is going to be 80 degrees
right for x 20 and they want to know by
how many degrees is the measure of the
largest angle exceed the measure of the
smallest angle so it's 80 minus 40 the
largest minus the smallest 80 minus 40
is equal to 40 and that is choice C next
problem
switch colors problem 13 the rate the
rate for telephone call between CDA and
city B is fifty cents so A to B is fifty
cents for the first minute and thirty
cents for each minute or portion thereof
so 50 minutes but fifty cents for the
first minute and then every extra minute
you try to study sense so thirty cents
every extra minute so if n is the number
of minutes the first minutes there so
every minute above the first minute so
that's n minus 1 right if you do it for
two minutes you get charged 50 cents and
then 2 minus 1 is 1 so then plus thirty
cents right and this is for n minutes
i'm assuming n is minutes alright which
of the following functions describes the
cost in dollars of a phone call between
the two cities that lasts for 10 minutes
if n is a positive integer alright well
what did I right here look what choice
is that that is choice D and once again
how did I think about this if I say you
know the cost of n minutes it's a
function of n minutes it equals well the
first minute is going to be fifty cents
and then for every minute after the
first minute so every minute after the
first minute can be represented by n
minus 1 right the second minute so 2-1 i
get i get charged one minute after the
first minute this will have to be 42
minutes and for every minute after the
first minute i'm going to get charged 30
cents so that's how we did it problem 14
I don't know if F actually let me just
do this in the next video because i have
to do just three more problems so might
as well just do a video for it I'll see
in the next